[Music]
alright so there does seem to me to be a
rebirth of a defense of free speech
starting again on the left possibly I
see a little southern happening I said
Jonathan Haidt at heterodox and some of
the other organizations you're involved
in and fire there is this group of
people kind of making a comeback on the
left I'm not so sure it can hold I hope
it can hold but what do you make of how
this sort of bounces back where
sometimes free speech is something that
the left holds more dear sometimes it's
something the right holds more dear and
it kind of switches as the decades
well my perspective and I'm not far be
it for me to pull out the age card but I
think I said a few more decades than you
have and and then it's been a constant
that was very well summed up by Nat
Hentoff whom you would have loved I
don't know if you ever crossed paths
with him but he was a great free speech
stalwart and he wrote a book whose title
really says it all freedom of speech for
me but not for the how the left and
right relentlessly censor each other and
he wrote that decades ago but it's
always been true that most people being
human believe in free speech in general
but those ideas that they hate or
despise or think are dangerous should be
the exception let's go back to Skokie
where ACLU members even 15% of these
die-hard stalwart ACLU members I'm not
surprised that the one exception they
want to make is for speech that's
denigrating civil liberties and human
rights but I had a friend who was the
executive director of the National
Coalition against censorship and she put
it so well she said Nadine everyone has
his or her Skokie
so at particular times I can tell you
for every year I can tell you this was
the one exception or maybe more than one
exception that liberals wanted to make
and this is the one that conservatives
wanted to make and I would say in
general you know like let's amend the
Constitution so that
is a crime to burn the American flag
that has been supported by many if not
most conservatives and by a lot of
liberals as well that and there's not
been I think that is the single most
hated expression in my lifetime because
no other expression has led to a
constitutional amendment coming within a
hair's breadth of being ratified more
than two-thirds of the Senate I'm sorry
if the House approved it came within one
one vote short of two-thirds of the
Senate and more than three-fourths of
the state's so all that's not that long
when was that maybe that was mid-90s
yeah something around there wow that's
incredible actually if you think about
it yeah where do you think Trump kind of
fits into the general discussion because
I say look it seems to me that there is
obviously some sort of authoritarian
bent to him that being said we're not
being people are as far as I know people
are being jailed because of free speech
at the moment do you think our
institutions let's say that his worst
critics his were right about whatever
they think about him do you think our
institutions at this point are strong
enough to ward off that kind of threat
and we don't even have to make about
Trump specifically but if there was
truly like a real authoritarian in
office do you think that the the way our
balance of powers and our separation of
powers works and again I would have to
say you know Trump has certainly done a
lot of saber rattling on free speech
issues and you know said that flag
burners should be deported but let us
not forget that Barack Obama was
responsible for the most stringent
enforcement of the Espionage Act and you
know pressing criminal charges against
more whistleblowers than all pre or
prior administrations added together so
again a pox on both your houses so far
the courts have been a wonderful bulwark
the flag burning example is is a really
good one it was a to Supreme Court
decisions joined by both conservatives
and liberals on the court that struck
down under the First Amendment
laws that criminalized desecrating the
american flag well the Supreme Court
doesn't have quite the last word a
constitutional amendment could overturn
it but I have great confidence that this
Court would continue to uphold what has
been called the bedrock principle of
freedom of speech and that is viewpoint
neutrality I summarized it earlier that
the mere fact that the viewpoint is
hated whether it be flag-burning or
whether it be racist speech that is
never a justification for censorship
again they unanimously endorsed that
last summer in a hate speech case yeah
let's slightly shift for a second so
when you were the head of the ACLU what
are the political pressures that you're
under that maybe the average person
wouldn't know from that from the
headlines like involvement with pop you
know politicians with lobbyists et
cetera et cetera so the ACLU was is and
I was personally involved in in lobbying
and testifying I still do testify before
Congress occasionally and I would say to
me it was a very privileged position
because we did not have to be directly
concerned about partisan political
pressures we could simply make alliances
and work with anybody that we thought
could support an issue that advanced our
cause even if we disagreed with them on
other issues and I remember to me it was
a great source of pleasure I remember on
one piece of legislation testifying
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
and the chair was Orrin Hatch and that
ranking minority member was Ted Kennedy
and they were both supporting this same
Pro civil liberties positions and I was
testifying together with the head of the
National Association of Evangelicals
and the head of the Mormon Church and
despite all of the differences on so
many other issues the fact that we could
make common concern that was on
principles of religious liberty and
freedom of thought and freedom of belief
that's what I feel is deteriorating a
little bit so last year I testified a
couple of times on campus free speech
issues and the bipartisanship had really
worn down even though the theme was
freedom of speech on campus and even
though the chair of the committee who
was Lamar Alexander Republican and patty
Murray the ranking member Democrat they
were both really solid and great on the
issue but the other members of the
committee just used it as opportunities
to trot out their own ideas of which
free speech was bad and should be
suppressed so some of the Republicans
were saying taking a knee by athletes
should be punished and some of the
Democrats were really saying Trump is
violating free speech and there was too
much political grandstanding right and
that's why far as critical as I am for
the left I don't want free speech to
become I don't want it to be a political
issue in the first place I don't want it
to be that the right which at the moment
I see more tolerance related to
diversity of ideas I don't want that to
be the home I want there to be a balance
otherwise we're just gonna end up in
that right well it may be a little bit
skeptical but I think that people tend
to be result oriented and that on the
right there may be much more support for
freedom of speech on campus because they
see that its views on the right that are
being squelch now in fairness I'll give
you a counter example many years ago
during this first surge of political
correctness on campus Mitch McConnell
let me play me and let me put it
backwards
it was Henry Hyde I'm sorry a
conservative Catholic from Illinois who
was completely on the opposite side of
the ACLU on abortion and gay rights he
really was so strong on campus free
speech that he sponsored a bill that
would have required all private
universities to respect the same free
speech rights that public universities
are required to observe under the
Constitution many people don't know this
Constitution only applies to government
including state universities but not
private university how do you guys feel
about well we've totally supported the
legislate Aryans and civil libertarians
my libertarian friends would say you
know keep the government out of it let
the private institutions decide and
there were exemptions for religious
institutions but basically I think
that's where I would fall on this so
sell me sell me your way it's a very
interesting debate and I can understand
but the person you know I've had this
discussion with my dear friends of the
Cato Institute for many many years now
what's the difference between a
classical liberal or libertarian and
civil libertarian I think that we are
less opposed to government regulation
when it is in the service of regulating
very powerful private sector actors that
for all practical purposes the way we
were talking about civil society earlier
can exercise coercive power that stifles
people's Liberty so so what if you you
know if you if if we did not have the
1964 Civil Rights Act then even the most
powerful large landlord employer
corporation private university or etc
would be able to discriminate on the
basis of race or gender under federal
law they still can on the basis of
sexual orientation I would view that as
something that could and should be
remedied through passing a statute
making that illegal hmm Richard Enda
well I think well first off I agree with
you your basic premise here just that
the idea level it's a great place for a
rich conversation yeah the idea that the
government would be coming in and
telling private schools even though I
understand what you're saying that they
would have to adhere to these codes even
if I being the First Amendment right
yeah I don't necessarily think a private
school should have to do that I just
think that ultimately the market would
just you either decide you want to go
there or don't want to go there this one
this one's definitely tough it's an
interesting one and I definitely can see
the other side and I certainly wouldn't
just on some exemptions certainly for
religious schools I think military
schools were also exempted but then I
want to give you another example of a
Republican that I worked with Mitch
McConnell works very closely with the
ACLU in opposing many people are going
to be surprised to hear this the
mccain-feingold law a campaign so called
campaign finance like a lifetime ago we
talked about a CLU very you know we are
the ones who argued Buckley versus Valeo
and arguing that the ability to spend
money in order to promote a message is
protected free speech and it should be
protected even when the speech is
engaged in by people who are organized
into a group and including if they're
organized in the form of a corporation
or a union or not-for-profit corporation
so some liberals are really distressed
by that position I think it's absolutely
the correct line anyway what do you say
to those those liberals or the lefties
who do get more upset about that in
general that you're just going to allow
corporations to endlessly pour money in
the system and manipulate the system and
that's it well again what is the lesser
of two evils would I rather have the
government telling corporations such as
the ACLU and Planned Parenthood and the
Sierra Club you name your favorite
left-wing so-called cause and it is
organized in corporate form and the ACLU
under that law was it would have been a
crime to go on the airwaves and by name
call on people who are running for
federal office and say you know repeal
the Patriot Act because arguing for
issues over the broadcast airwaves was a
crime under that law and spending your
own money to advance your own
issue-oriented message so I think people
are shocked when they hear what the law
actually did and are persuaded that in
at least some applications that went too
far
well McConnell became such
a supporter of free speech as a result
of working on this issue that he
actually changed his position on the
flag burning amendment he had been a big
proponent of it and as having seen how
important freedom of speech was
including for what two liberals is a
very controversial form of speech namely
spending money in the political process
he said well you know I've got to stick
to principles here and we should not
amend the Constitution to outlaw another
controversial expression so I thought
that was a really wonderful idea of not
just being result oriented toward your
own ideological concerns but seeing
their overarching principle and
following it it's almost like if you
actually have the debate you might
change people's mind and be surprised to
your allies suddenly are is there any
country that is protecting these rights
better than we are now for as screwy as
our system may be no well let me make on
sexual expression the United States is
much more repressive than European some
many European countries but like in what
regard you mean with yeah so we still
have I mean not only sexual expression
but four-letter words I mean thank
goodness we're not broadcasting because
I still get bleeped even when I say
whatever you are you're all seven of
them okay well and and when one of them
appears and I'm not even sure if this
was one of these seven but [ __ ] the
draft was upheld as of in a very
important free speech case it by the
United States Supreme Court and this is
a case that has ramifications for hate
speech as well but I cannot describe the
facts of that case on radio or TV and
the another country and we still have
anti obscenity law I mean let's not
forget that the brouhaha about the the
wardrobe malfunction at Super Bowl I
mean
it's so we're much more puritanical but
when it comes to political expression
there's no country that gives as much
protection as we do including for
hateful racist speech and misogynistic
speech including for defamation
you know defamatory falsehoods about
public officials and public figures and
that's why there are so many libel
lawsuits that are brought in the UK
against what would be clearly protected
speech in this country yeah but you do
believe in our libel laws here yes I you
know I I'm sure I would want to trim
them back a little bit but on the whole
we're quite protective so if it's a
matter of public concern or public
official or public figure you get quite
a bit of leeway you can't be held
culpable unless you have acted
intentionally or recklessly and I think
that's correct and one of the time
they're pretty specific yeah one of the
things that that Trump wanted to do as
he said was to reform the libel laws to
make it easier for a public official to
to collect damages and you know a lot of
people say oh come on Nadine Britain and
Germany and France and Canada and
Australia you know it's not as if they
are to tell eteri in authoritarian
countries but if you read the examples
in my book of the kinds of speech that
are being punished even with
imprisonment even with criminal fines
and that's the tip of the iceberg
because for every punishment there is
there are countless numbers of of
self-censorship
incidents it would really make your skin
crawl give examples no matter what your
ideology is you should find something in
there that you would say oh my goodness
I can't believe it so you know France a
couple of years ago criminally convicted
the head of a gay rights organization
for calling the head of an anti gay
rights organization a homophobe that was
considered to be hate speech now
fortunately she wasn't sentenced to
prison but she was subject to a very
stiff fine
$3,500 and and and then you think what
are the ripple effects of that yeah
have you guys tracked this case with the
comedian in the UK who had the dog oh
yeah a salute yes I mean again like it's
like all right first up he was making a
joke there's no there's no exception for
humor or satire when the new online hate
speech laws went into effect in Germany
on January 1st the first person
convicted or charged under it was one of
the leaders of a right-wing party not
surprisingly but the very and then maybe
the first two that were charged were
from that party but the very next one
was a satirical magazine that was making
fun of their statements mocking them
ridiculing and and and and these laws by
being so subjective can't make the fine
distinctions between humorous satire and
straightforward advocacy yeah so my
audience knows I'm not big on the the
globalist ideas here or even the UN I
think it's mostly a forest at this point
but do we need some sort of internet
Bill of Rights I mean this is a new
phrase that we're that seems to be
popping up over the last year or so that
will uniformly protect people in other
country from via for their ability to
say things that are uncomfortable online
and be able to tweet things that you
know you can't say in Germany but you
can't say in the United States I I think
we have to do that on a
country-by-country basis and I am
pleased that there are advocates in
other countries that really strongly
support freedom of speech including for
hate speech I keep putting that in their
quotes because it as I say to that
person at the University of New
Hampshire no there really is no such
thing and by the way there a lot of what
they said to you some people would
consider to be hate speech too so that's
another argument that you could have
made my one regret is at one point when
she said to me I said something about
losing Holocaust family members from how
goes on both sides and then later she
said they're rolling in their graves
over what I'm
I mean try to think like if this if
we're really if we're really gauging the
offense meter yeah I assure you there
was nothing that I said in those two
hours that was more wildly offensive
than that but do I want her jailed
because of that I mean of course not
yeah so I really was heartened at how
much support there is for the American
approach we're often attacked as being
American Exceptionalist and it wouldn't
bother me if we were the only ones in
the in the world that were defending our
free speech principles as long as that
is the right thing to do but it's
interesting that other people having
seen despite the good intentions of
sensorial laws elsewhere how they are
leading to results that no thinking
person should accept and handing over to
these online so here we get to this
question again I'll put it this way Dave
what's the lesser of two evils to allow
these private agglomerations of power
Internet companies decide pick and
choose whose speech is allowed and who's
not and enforcing their own concepts of
hate speech or pornography or
permissible or impermissible nudity to
pick just a few examples that they
enforce would I rather have them have
that enormous power or would I rather
have the government say no we're gonna
check your power to restrict other
people's free speech rights and to me
that's a very difficult yes so that's
okay so that's exactly where we were
before with the universities and that's
where I would say ultimately right now
are for I don't know how many internet
companies we have let's say comcast
spectrum they're all one that's been
that neutrality issue and I'm thinking
of the social media that you know the
Facebook's and the Twitter's having
these armies of enforcers saying that's
hate speech we're gonna take it down
right so I guess what I would say is
that if there were certain internet
companies that were saying all right
well we're not going to allow
pornography on our pipes or we're not
going to allow this type of speech or
that that was which I would still prefer
that you as the consumer would have more
choice exactly
then then the government saying we have
to enforce all these things totally but
because of the int because of the
internet now I know this is a unique
situation related to free speech that's
a little I mean in my ideal world I'm
completely with you the question is and
I'm not an economist my husband is and
he tells me that it's very complicated
have some of them amassed so much power
that word that we should use antitrust
type tools to prevent them for that that
they are denying us choice through their
market power right so this is it there's
a great conversation to be had there
this is where my friends at Prager
University who I agree with on all sorts
of stuff they were suing Google YouTube
over restrictions to their videos which
I wasn't for because I don't want the
antitrust stuff to be in because to me
that that then means you just create a
zillion other problems down the road
but that's a great place for a free
speech person and an economist and
probably a technology guy to all sit
down and work this stuff out without
choking each other there was a really
really frightening story in The New York
Times a few weeks ago
featuring Facebook's deletion Center
that's what it was actually called this
huge building in Berlin where they had
literally hundreds of people that are
looking at individual posts in deciding
should this be deleted it should not be
deleted and it was you know in the
examples you you realize how inevitably
subjective it is ultimately they took
down when they took down this this
comment that was posted by the
politician she was calling certain
Muslim men rapists and the question was
was she referring to the particular
Muslim immigrants who were in fact
convicted rapists there was a horrible
incident on New Year's Eve a couple of
years ago in which case one would hope
that would be protected speech because
she's describing something actual or was
she perhaps insinuating that all Muslim
men are rapists which would not would be
a generalization that I would find
objectionable but and but it would be
illegal under German law and the
official you know these people it's
their whole job
to make these decisions they couldn't
agree between themselves and so of
course if you're not sure which way it
goes and you're facing a 50 million euro
fine if the German government says it is
hate speech
well guess which way yeah yeah what do
you think right now is our biggest
censorship threat what do you think is
coming on the horizon I'm going to be
very general because it's been the same
answer I've had throughout my decades of
activism which is lack of public
understanding and awareness of what the
First Amendment is what it does protect
what it does not protect what the
rationales are I truly believe that the
more people understand both what the
principles are and how we have evolved
toward those principles through historic
experience that people will be
supportive so I'm curious during the
whole NFL kneeling thing I've made a
couple videos about it and obviously we
talked about it on the show but I
basically was saying look this is free
speech working the president said what
he said now I would certainly prefer
that the president not call people sons
of [ __ ] right but he's entitled to
free speech he didn't try to enact a law
to stop him
so he spoke the players could then kneel
or not kneel so they were able to do
what they wanted the owners could then
you know find the players or not so they
got to do what they wanted the fans
could say I'm gonna buy jerseys and
attend games or I'm not gonna do so
everyone's speech actually everyone's
speech and action was protected you
might have some consequences for it but
to me it was a great example of the
whole thing working messy but working do
you do you think that's a fair
information slowly agree with that and
I'm had quite similar analysis myself to
the disappointment of people who did not
realize that the NFL as a private entity
has its own rights including its own
free speech rights and I thought it was
interesting that some of the owners said
they would allow their players to
express their their protest is in that
case though is Trump getting it as close
to where it could be an issue for the AC
you or other similar organizations as he
can without directly calling for a law
because there is some other well I don't
even know what that phrase is but
there's something else happening there
when he's calling he were threatening if
he were threatening to pass a law yeah
and he did that in one other context I
think he threatened that there should be
some FN FCC license should be taken away
from some broadcaster that comes much
closer to line and the principal Dave
you're exactly right he does not give up
his free speech rights by virtue of
being a government official but if he is
speaking in official capacity and
threatening some adverse consequences
that could be seen as an abridgment of
free speech under which would visor
yeah so in the past I think the closest
Supreme Court case we have is where a
government Commission wrote a letter
that threatened that it would take some
action and even though it wasn't
starting a prosecution or it wasn't an
order to cease the expression the court
said you know it was a very functional
practical concept it would a reasonable
person feel deterred in pursuing their
free speech after they hear this
communication and again reasonable
people can disagree about what the
answer to that is but that's the
question we should put in evaluating
whether Trump has crossed the line or
not so one of the things that I saw when
the NFL released its new standard now
for next season where the players are
allowed to stay in the locker room or
not and again everyone's choice will
will or will not have consequence I saw
a lot of people that were saying well
clearly the government involved you know
interfered behind the scenes now I know
there's no I know you don't suspect you
don't have some sort of outside
knowledge something like that that's
where there would be a problem though if
they were really you know behind the
scenes meetings where they were saying
you're going to institute this new
policy and that's a yawn but short of
having that information everything kind
of worked yeah there there's another
analogy I can think of which is where
the government has threatened certain
businesses that if you don't adopt a
voluntary restriction on speech then
we're going to pass legislation so for
example the movie rating system or sound
recording rating systems that we think
these labels are stigmatizing and
therefore suppressing certain expression
I think there's a very strong argument
that the only reason this so-called
voluntary system was put in place in
both businesses is because they knew
that if they didn't do it the government
was going to legislate it but even that
the Supreme Court never held that that
was illegal censorship yeah all right
well we can't talk free speech for an
hour and not mention the cake we got to
talk about the gay cake tell me your
thoughts on the game cake okay it's AI
first of all I think it involves not
only expression which I would define
quite broadly and again let me talk
about the the standard here reasonable
people can disagree how the standard
applies to the facts of the case so the
court has said and I think this is
correct that something comes some
expression comes or arguable expression
comes within the ambit of the First
Amendment if it is intended to and can
reasonably perceived as conveying a
message at least a general message so
that's the question you would ask about
the cake I think there's at least a
plausible argument that the cake is
satisfied that standard in addition to
expression there's the question of
religious liberty right which I defend
very strongly even more strongly than
the Supreme Court which has a quite
narrow definition now but I think people
should not be coerced generally to do
something that violates their deeply
held religious or conscientious police
that's only one side of the equation
though because neither free no speech
nor religious freedom is absolute and in
general the court has said and I think
this is right that government can
restrict those freedoms if it can show
that there is a counter
veiling interest of such compelling
importance that can only be advanced by
restricting the expression or the belief
and the countervailing interest is of
course the dignity and equality of in
this case gay people but in past cases
has been african-americans or women
because people have cited who are in
business have asserted religious
justifications for not serving members
of racial minorities are not treating
women equally and but to be clear that's
not what was happening here because they
could have walked in and bought any cake
off the shelf a black person interracial
couple could have walked in and bought
any cake off the shelf this was about
the specific act that was going to be
paint you know painted or whatever they
do on the game right you know it's
interesting I and there's another
another free speech principle that's
involved here which is that government
may not compel somebody to proclaim a
certain message that they don't believe
in any more than it may stop somebody
from conveying a message that they that
they do believe in so I would say I'm
I'm very I think they're very strong
concerns on both sides so I'm very
sympathetic because let me finish out
the other argument of course if you're
an independent artist that is you know
only taking assignments on commission
whether it be to paint a portrait or a
landscape or to decorate a cake in a
very elaborate way that's one thing but
if you are doing business with the
general public and basically holding
yourself out as what the law would call
a public accommodation we're open to
all-comers then you may not discriminate
on certain basis such as race religion
and I think even though you still can as
a matter of federal law under state law
in that state and and and others you
cannot do that on the basis of sexual
orientation and so I think that very
strong
equality principle I think should should
dominate in in this analysis so you
actually weren't thrilled with this
decision
well I was I was in the sense that there
were so many ways that the court could
have gone wrong so many issues well they
said that it was a the best thing they
could do was to be very narrow and I
actually if I were writing in the brief
in the case that's what I would do to
because all of these principles are so
important I deeply care about freedom of
expression including the freedom not to
be compelled to affirm a message that
that violates your beliefs whether
they're religious or conscientious
doesn't matter but I also deeply believe
in equality in the public sphere and the
facts were murky so I think you know as
I think what happened in past situations
with race and gender I think you know
once things once the immediate
resistance died down to the 1964 Civil
Rights Act that it sort of worked its
way out in a way that is maximally
respective respectful of all the
competing rights so I think it's very
good to avoid really broad brush
holdings that might have unanticipated
adverse consequences for other factual
situations that's an interesting take
because I saw some people saying well
they're just sort of kicking this down
the road now but basically they're
saying in a weird way that's the way a
functional society works at times I
think you know the court sets some
general goal posts and then as time goes
by the controversy may die down people
may figure out how they can live their
own lives in ways that they're not going
to be bothered by by the government not
being treated disrespectfully one of the
things that I really liked about the
opinion in that case and it's so
contrasting to what's happening in the
European countries that I discuss in my
book is that the court talked very
strongly about equality and neutrality
in many
different sorry in many different
contexts so not only that you should be
treated with equal dignity regardless of
who you are but also regardless of what
you believe so the fact that the court
was respectful both of the equal dignity
of the gay couple and of the equal
dignity of the religious beliefs and the
free speech rights of the Baker I really
liked that I'm one of the things that
bothers me very much about what is often
paraded as diversity on campus is that
it only looks at one dimension it looks
at demographic diversity in terms of who
you are but not in terms of of what you
believe and in these European countries
that are enforcing hate speech laws you
see them going both ways depending on
who's in power so certain religious
beliefs are being punished and
criminalized as hate speech if they run
against what is a dominant secular
orthodoxy in those societies whereas in
others communities certain criticism of
religion is treated as hate speech and
criminalized when it's the religious
belief that is held by those in dominant
power I think the main takeaway here is
that freedom is messy but we're doing a
pretty decent job of it here well thanks
to those who keep agitating right
eternal vigilance there you go well it's
been a pleasure chatting with you and
for more on Nadine check out her new
book hate why we should resist it with
free speech not censorship and we're
going to link to it right down below
[Music]